حشود ضخمه اكتداد شديد وتوابير وطويله في
محطه القطارات في كل من مدينه شنغهاي
وبكين الصينيتين
فهؤلاء المسافرون لديهم رغبه واحده فقط ان
يجتمعوا بعائلتهم للاحتفال بالعام القمري
الجديد بعد عامين من الاجراءات الوقائيه
الصارمه التي طبقت الحكومه الصينيه بسبب
كوفي 19
سنه
منذ عامين
واصيب بفيروس ايضا لكنهما بخير الان لذلك
علينا العوده الى المنزل
عائلتنا منذ فتره طويله
السلطات الصينيه وقعت تسجيل اكثر من مليار
رحله بين الشهر الجاري والمقبل اي ضعف ما
سجل العام الماضي
تعاني من نقص في تجهيزات مخاوف قللت منها
لجنه الصحه في بيانات جديده
الذروه باتت وراءنا
وبمناسبه عطله راس السنه الجديده تم توزيع
الاقنعه والمطهرات على 35 الف اسره في
مقاطعه
اكثر من 400 عياده في المناطق الريفيه وهي
مفتوحه على مدار اليوم